Hello and welcome to this course on Data Analytics with Excel.
My name is Jaidev, Jaidev Deshpande and I am Associate Principal Data Scientist at Gramener
which is a data science company.
So you see we are collecting more and more data than ever before in history and there
is an entire industry around analyzing and interpreting bad data.
The objective of this course is to not only make you comfortable with the practice of
data analytics but also to make you significantly competent within this industry.
So far we have mostly been grasping at straws.
Analysis has not been able to keep up with the volume of data.
It seems like no matter how much money or energy we invest in analyzing data we cannot
keep up with the demand.
One of the major reasons why this happens is because data analysis as an industrial
discipline tends to be fairly ad-hoc in its approach to data that is.
One of the most important things that you are going to learn in this course is how to
take a structured approach towards analyzing data.
You will see that having a structure, a process makes you significantly more effective.
It brings more discipline and more rigor to the practice.
It helps you avoid wastage which is a wastage of analysis, a wastage of energy and ultimately
wastage of time and money as well.
So since it's a well defined, well structured process with some luck you should be able
to also automate this process.
The final aspect of this course is the tool that we will use which is spreadsheets.
Spreadsheets have quite simply changed the world.
If we as a species were to face extinction and had to preserve say our top five technologies
then spreadsheets would definitely be among them.
In fact, Fred Brooks said that spreadsheets are one of the biggest innovations in computer
science since databases and high level programming languages.
Excel is quite simply the single most versatile analytical tool anybody can use.
Dollar for dollar it far outweighs pretty much anything else.
Of course, note that whatever we do with Excel in this course should also be doable with
any other spreadsheet software like LibreOffice, KLC or Google Sheets.
Having said that, also note that we will only be using Excel as a vehicle for analytics
in the analytics industry.
The only thing as abundant as the data itself is opinions about which tool is the best.
And I believe that the sooner you try to lay this question to rest the better.
My current boss is S. Anand who is the CEO of Gramener and consistently ranked in the
top 10 data scientists in India.
He says that tools do not matter, technique does.
A good analyst is someone who is able to perform good analysis with any tool.
The best tool you have is between your ears.
So ultimately my job here is to teach you the process and the methods of data analysis
with Microsoft Excel just as a tool as a vehicle.
You should be able to replicate this process with any other tool that you are comfortable
with.
That would be a good test of how well you have understood the material.
So with that, let's begin.